[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
a few weeks ago a driver for a charter
bus company
reached out to reporters at fox 17 in
nashville
she'd been told not to speak to the
media but she did it anyway
why because what she was seeing every
day on the job was so strange so without
precedent in her 20-year career as a
driver
that she felt she had to tell the public
about it starting this april the bus
driver said government agents began
instructing her to pick up
busloads of migrant children foreign
nationals from guatemala mexico honduras
etc
the driver wasn't given any information
beyond that she was just told to take
those children
deep into the interior of the united
states away from the border
and do it as quickly as possible quote
there have been some drop-offs in
nashville
some in knoxville some in chattanooga a
couple in atlanta the driver said that's
just as far as i go
then the children continue on further
another source familiar with what's
going on
told fox 17 that some of these foreign
nationals were taken as far away as new
york and chicago and miami
but there's a problem if you're trying
to change the population of a country
without the people who already live
there finding out
it's tough to do it with buses because
when you pull a bus
packed with illegal migrants from a
foreign country without the proper idea
without the right to be in this country
at all
people tend to notice so the byte
administration
came up with a different plan quote now
they're flying the kids because the
buses were easier to videotape going
down the highway
ask yourself by the way since we've been
talking a lot about democracy in this
country everything is a threat to
democracy
if you change the population of a
country without the consent of the
people who live there is that democracy
doesn't that country belong to the
people who live there it's their country
that's what democracy is
but what if a small number of hardened
ideologues decided to take it away from
those people and give it to foreign
nationals that would not be democracy
by the way some of the footage of buses
hauling illegal migrants was shot by the
center for immigration studies back in
march and we have a clip
here it is what's happening most of the
time is that they are boarding buses
and heading into america's heartland a
conveyor belt of commercial and charter
buses
just like this one in del rio texas are
carrying tens of thousands
sight unseen from texas arizona and
california borderlands
northward and they are dropping their
haitian venezuelan
cuban and central american family units
in florida and new jersey tennessee
massachusetts michigan north carolina
georgia kentucky
and to large cities in texas such as
dallas and houston
how is this not the biggest story in the
country you're changing the population
of america
without the consent of americans you're
doing it
secretly on a huge scale and no one's
noticing
six months after inauguration day the
borders are more open than ever
it tells you everything you need to know
about how the biden administration
approaches immigration they're not going
to stop the flow
of illegal migrants across our southern
border no instead they give those
migrants free transportation to anywhere
in the united states
they choose and when you notice that
they're doing it they don't stop
they just find a different way to do it
a new method of transportation
how is this not an invasion that's
exactly what it is
and it's being embedded by the biden
administration here are the numbers
in may of last year a total of 24
000 people were encountered by
authorities at the southwestern land
border in may of this year that number
had risen
to 180 thousand 180 000 people
that's the equivalent of the entire city
of chattanooga tennessee
showing up at the southern border every
single month and we're not
cherry-picking data by the way that's
true every month last april for example
17 000 people showed up at the southern
border this april the number was
seventy eight thousand it's that kind of
increase
dramatic to the point that your eyes
pop open every month of this year
since joe biden became president in all
the number of illegal immigrants
crossing the u.s mexico border this
fiscal year is already at its highest
level since 2006
with four months still uncounted here's
what it actually looks like at the rio
grande
in less than an hour the smugglers have
brought a group of at least 60 migrants
into the united states
just in this spot alone many of them
women
and children border patrol buses can't
get down to the river's edge so
agents have to lead the migrants up a
hill to a processing area that's where
they're joined by
other migrants who have also illegally
crossed on rafts in the area
it's big business for the human
smugglers who continue to benefit the
most
from the ongoing border crisis
so that report makes an important point
a lot of people coming over just
economic migrants are moving from very
poor countries to the largest welfare
state in the world which is
our country and why wouldn't they do
that you'd probably do the same if you
could
we shouldn't allow them but you can't
blame them for wanting to
but not all of them are good people with
obvious human motives like that some of
them are very bad people
some of them have pre-existing criminal
records according to customs and border
protection immigration authorities have
arrested 760 illegal migrants since
october just in the laredo section of
the texas border
last year during the same period they
arrested only 60 people
so that's a 900 increase in the number
of illegal immigrants detained with
criminal backgrounds by the way
that's not all who came here those are
the ones that we detain
we should tell you that includes sex
offenders and gang members
not just drunk drivers and it includes a
lot of drug traffickers mexico is in the
middle of a drug war right now a real
one
according to the texas department of
public safety just in the last year
fentanyl seizures at the southern border
have surged more than 800 percent and
that's
just in texas keep in mind fentanyl is
extremely difficult to detect it doesn't
take much
it's odorless and colorless it's very
easy to smuggle fentanyl that's why they
do it
seeing the od rates in the united states
they're off
the charts those deaths are being fed by
the drug trade coming across
our southern border it's killing
americans
so this is a disaster and the numbers
prove it but according to kamala harris
it's progress to the men and women who
are on the ground doing the job
every day i commend all of them for
the success that they have seen thus far
i call it progress
we're not exactly where we want to be
yet but we have seen extreme progress
over these last few months
extreme progress as the numbers rise
and as the biden administration without
your permission
or knowledge but at your expense moves
some unknown
thousands of people into the interior of
the united states where they begin new
lives
again on federal programs not a slam on
them
but it's an attack and when we should
all join in on the people making it
possible the question is what can you do
about it the administration's out of
control there's no oversight at all from
the congress
certainly not from the media the stakes
couldn't be higher
at this point there's only one way to
stop it there's only one man who can his
name is greg abbott
he is the governor of texas the governor
of texas could send the national guard
to the border and seal it it's his
border
too there are 19 thousand soldiers in
the texas national guard as of tonight
we believe greg abbott has deployed a
mere 500 of them
to the border why is that why not seal
the border between texas and mexico
california's not going to do it arizona
may or may not texas could tomorrow
why aren't they we wanted to ask greg
abbott that question but he refused to
come on
one senior official in the state of
texas has agreed to address that
question then we're going to talk to him
in just a minute
we want to begin tonight with someone
who is down there
firsthand seeing what's happening one of
the few reporters who has covered
our open borders and that's julia rosas
last night he was in roma texas while he
was speaking a coyote showed up bringing
migrants across the river in a raft
here's what it looked like
we are here in roma texas right now the
rio grande is right behind me
and what's going on right now is the
coyotes are bringing over
the illegal immigrants right here this
spot in roma is a very popular crossing
area there's no border patrol there's no
national guard there's no
texas highway patrol it's just it's just
us they're over here
and uh there's still more people across
the bank from us as well so
this is far from the last trip